off the rails today's a great app
oh no oh oh it's the wally express
oh
what a nightmare
we are truly off the rails today boys
having vietnam flashbacks
thousand mile stare
[Music]
uh today is off the rails baby sponsored
by policy genius curology and kraken
lots of good stuff today
today
is the day of lots of good stuff
thank you thank you
today we are competing to see who has
the most cursed
tick tock page good morning my queens of
tick-tock above 18. love 18. oh no
important asterisks
so what happened was ian gave us all a
fresh login
and we have been dedicated this past
week to scrolling and liking
to get the most cursed
possible tick tock page with a fresh
account so we'll get into that later i'm
pretty excited though
um
but at the top of the show we've got
plenty to get to for example did you
guys know you guys remember gal gadot's
imagine with all the celebs that
everyone hated
she was trying to what she was trying to
fix covet or something and she got all
the celebs to sing imagine it was and it
clearly worked yeah well we're outta
kovit yep as you can tell
so somebody mysterious put together
they got all these the usual suspects to
recreate gaga notes imagine
using h3 cameos
and you guys had did you guys have any
idea that this was going on by the way i
am not associated with this at all
so
i initially
uh declined the request and then he told
me that i was the only one that declined
so uh interesting i didn't want to be
above scale so i ended up doing it for
him now what was your reasoning for
declining
because i can't sing oh interesting wow
i uh i had no clue to be honest yeah you
can tell watching zack zack's was just
super into it
it's like yeah he's played this song
i'll [ __ ] play this song well you get
you get song requests all the time
that's like par for the course for you
right right yes but ian you got roped in
my parents obviously i don't think they
know any i don't think they know what's
going on
ian did you know no i i mean it was a
little weird because he said sing up to
this point specifically and i i didn't
do that right
you took the money though
i did the intro i i pulled up the
uh
word for word uh preamble and i just
said that instead by the way um i
noticed you have the uh wings behind you
ian that's very beautiful and angelic of
you i thought to spruce it up yeah it's
nice
well here it is
um
apparently he spent what like uh 315
bucks to make this so there you go money
well spent
hey guys
day six
in self quarantine and
i gotta say that
these past few years
[Music]
yeah
so philosophical he ended so well
imitating spirus
has affected the entire
world it's hard to believe everyone
doesn't matter who
you are where you're from
we're all in this together
and
i saw
this video
of this italian guy playing trumpet
on his balcony
to all the other ones everyone was
locked down and broke and starving were
locked inside their homes and he was
playing imagine and there was something
so powerful and pure
about
this video
wow
and it goes like this
wait are we gonna get a claim for this
[ __ ] bro i don't know it's that good
it's gonna cost me a lot more than 315
dollars if we get claimed those vocals
are stellar dude i'll
once it gets to my part yeah let me just
give you that
oh gee sorry zack you're too good at it
bubba's only
[Music]
nothing to kill or
no it's short i think it's very short if
you just bro that's the beatles don't
[ __ ] around with that [ __ ]
true
that is just john lennon i'm not fine
sorry i i misspoke
living life and peace
you tried to sucker me into the song but
guess what i'm not gonna do it joker
brain baby wait gal did gal gadot say
that i don't remember that part of the
original brain
[Music]
zach i'm sorry i used your catchphrase i
apologize why don't you owe him
royalties for that one dude
zack stop with the sinking so good
you're gonna get my ass
slammed right take it as a compliment
yeah take it as a compliment here i am
excited about it gabe stole the show
but i'm not the only one [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
so michael i hope you enjoyed that
thanks zach i really did enjoy it oh
there's out there there's somebody else
on the street crew who made cameos i
know it was a bit of a weird request but
mama mia was that a spicy video also i
just want to say thank you to a street
crew for everything you do um i tune in
every single week and it's the highlight
of my week every single time so thanks
bro thanks for what you do and if you're
looking for somebody who's good behind
the camera oh [ __ ] it's just turning
into another work for higher pitch
[ __ ] you know they keep
anybody else feeling horny right now
[Music]
oh right this was the original
that inspired gal right right right
okay well shout out to a filmmaker
podcast for that one a high budget
production
well done
yeah sorry we had to skip you zack but
we know you sing and play beautifully
well thank you i i do take it as a
compliment
are my parents available for this story
um yeah i think so they are how many to
get them on because so you know i it
occurred to me actually let me show this
let me set him up with this i saw this
tweet
of this new amazon factory in tijuana
which is so dystopian and disturbing but
here it is
but of all these 10 episodes of families
we did it reminded me of one of my best
dad stories
i've ever
i've ever had and i never actually told
it i forgot about it so this is um
a beautiful brand new amazon factory
that's in the slums of tijuana
and it's just looks so [ __ ] up
it's just a it's a warehouse not a
factory they just okay
yeah a warehouse right but they ship and
fulfill there right
from what i understand what they're
actually doing there
is
circumventing trump's tariffs from china
so amazon's having all their ship from
china shipped to this place in tijuana
because it's only 20 minutes from the
border they disassemble stuff
there
and then put it in a truck and drive it
across the border to where it's not
taxed for tariff and then sell it in
america it's the middle man it's the
middle man yo jeff bezos is such an evil
[ __ ] sick [ __ ]
god what is wrong with that man i was
looking up how i know that like
obviously the wages in mexico are
obviously considerably lower but i think
like the average
i don't know bro
he's pa he's paying like a dollar 25
which i know is above the mexican
minimum wage but i was reading like the
average salary there is like you know
thirteen hundred dollars a month and
this is approximately like a hundred and
sixty dollars a month so oh yes
but
maybe it's good jobs for i mean
these people are not living very well
that's for sure around there
hell yes
but you know it's gonna be so dystopian
they're gonna have like barbed wire
fences will probably have armed guards
to keep the beef the slum people out
it's gonna be so [ __ ] there bro
hell this one just pay this this might
be the uh the employees
living in the slums that might just be
who works there no for sure it will be
yeah yeah for sure it will be uh your
mom's uh on the line would you like me
to bring her in for this story yeah okay
but do you what do you think like
obviously it's gonna give these people
like i guess
decent jobs so what what's globalization
how did you rate that globalization
effort on amazon square well i mean
like i said i mean this is all motivated
by
um you know tax codes and loopholes and
stuff that um
that exist that have existed since nafta
came into place before amazon even
existed they're they're
you know this is just how it works hello
yes it's quote unquote smart business
it'll probably help these people living
here though right man
i mean i guess it gives jobs but
apparently the you know like
all
amazon uh warehouses the conditions
not the best and enforced overtime and
all all that kind of good stuff which we
have here we're exporting we're this is
our our best export here in america is
um
uh over exploiting laborers hell yes oh
yes well i'm assuming the labor laws in
mexico are probably not that progressive
either but i don't know that for sure
but something tells me they can do
whatever they want with these people
short of
oh look who it is the celebrities here
they are
mom and dad
the the don arc
how you guys doing
good good we just came back from the
movies yeah what'd you guys see we went
we we saw
it was a marvel movie
and the ten rings was it good
it was really good and you know and you
know what the girl the concession stand
knew who we were so she gave us a lot of
pop oh damn perks baby wow family's fur
wow
[Applause]
so i wanted to tell a story
i saw this picture in am of that new
amazon uh warehouse in tijuana and it
reminded me of my favorite story about
dad that i never i forgot to tell when
we were on families so i'm going to tell
that story now and i thought you maybe
dad you should be here to defend
yourself at the very least
all right another chance for
uh
total humiliation online okay go for it
hey listen this is it is what it is i'm
airing my trauma this is how i cope and
this is the price you uh pay for that
free popcorn that's how it works yeah
exactly you can't be like oh free
popcorn and then oh don't talk about how
i traumatized you
first of all we paid for yeah we did pay
for the problem
tom just thinks she got extra she well
i thought she was very generous well
okay so that's not really
maybe why don't you remember you really
get a lot of pop you just topped it off
don't say their name i was gonna say
give her tell her name so she can get
fired yeah exactly no we paid we paid
for popcorn oh okay all right
do you know where she lives
no the employee did nothing wrong she
was very nice she was a doll she was a
very sweet girl
she's gonna get fired and she's gonna
write us and hold us responsible
we paid for the popcorn
they're gonna check the receipts now
we're gonna check the camera
all right so here's the story
me and my family
i think this was probably in high school
right uh
we went on a family trip to puerto
vallarta
we probably had like three days there
fun right relaxing good times not a lot
of time
three days now in puerto vallarta there
is basically like the beach resort area
and then there's the town where there's
kind of like the lo more locals but it's
it's still touristy there's like nice
restaurants and stuff
it's probably like a 20-minute drive
so my dad thought to himself we're
staying in the resort and he stinks to
himself what a great idea would it be
to instead of paying a taxi
which would cost like ten dollars
to buy public bus tickets
and pay like 10 cents or something
probably
right
it wasn't the money it was the
experience of being with the real people
in mexico that is such a lie
it was 100 the money
was not but go ahead okay that's such a
lie like okay so we're on vacation we
have limited time and my dad forces the
whole family onto a bus
for 10 cents
and he goes we'll just take the bus and
we'll go to the place and get off there
obviously we're the only white people
we're all the only oh well not white but
american we're non-mexican people on the
bus because who who who on vacation
wants to take first of all a bus
to save ten dollars well we get on the
we got on a bus and it's driving and
it's driving it's been like hours hours
do you understand what i'm saying this
is a 10-minute drive
it starts veering off
way off course and we end up like in the
absolute outskirts of puerto vallarta
and this it looked identical to this
neighborhood
it started to look like this the roads
were dirt it was all huts it was very
like third worldy
was actually shocking i never seen
conditions like that so it was
interesting in that regard but it's a
little scary because
we're very out of place
yeah and um
but beyond that we were on the bus now
for like three hours we're in the middle
of this like
oh it was the whole day we were all
freaking out
maybe 25 minutes oh my god we were
freaking out we're like where are we we
don't know what we're doing and then the
bus driver says this is the end of the
line in this neighborhood
and then we go
and then you say well can you take us
back right so he takes us back to the
bus stop back at the beginning and we're
all so miserable we're screaming at my
dad we feel unsafe and my dad just
locked dad you know how you just lock up
and sit there like this
and we're like dude what is going like
you're doing now
i don't know what you're talking and
we're all just like what the [ __ ] how
did you make us do this is horrible
wasting our whole one of our three days
all just on a bus going nowhere and we
get off and then finally we take a taxi
back to the um
the main place but we spent like the
whole day
just on a public bus while on vacation
so that's the story and it was uh
traumatic
and uh
horrible do you remember ethan when we
went to san francisco and dad was so
sure that we were going in the right
direction we ended up going up around
and around and around and up the hills
and it was hot
dad has a tendency to this is the way we
need to go and you know i don't remember
that you remember going to san francisco
with us i don't know
where were we we were climbing up hills
and we were lost maybe that wasn't
regarded so what do you say dad about
this experience have i re-told it
correctly mom dad anything you want to
add
no that sounds pretty much yeah although
you made a comment about the people that
were local i think we
we were living in mexico already at this
point and i think we drove from akihi to
puerto vallarta
we were visiting yeah we were definitely
visiting we we did not walk there yet
was this the trip sean wrecked his arm
or was that it no this is a different
trip
this is a different trip you're
digressing dad all right get out of here
you guys enjoy your free popcorn
all right thanks sam thank you for
coming for your job stephen murphy it
was really good it was a good movie okay
thank you
so
bye bye thanks guys
out
all right the next part i'm going to
blast through this but sam
has been absolutely obsessed sam you
better come defend this because i have a
hard time believing this is going to be
good stand up sam it's taco bell
you know all the fried chicken sandwich
crazes so taco bell's like all right
let's get in on this and they have
released a fried chicken taco
um
that looks horrid let's be honest oh and
then where's the picture you sent sam uh
you sent a are ian you sent a funny
photo oh
i got it yeah pulled that chicken
all right yeah you're getting it and
then do you have a picture of sam
sleeping with her like she's like that's
what i thought you were talking about
she's literally passing out with fried
chicken sandwiches in her hands
you love this sandwich sam don't you
it is so good you could say that oh my
god bro
what happened here this is real
it was so late last night and i was so
tired but i was starving and i had just
gotten home from watching bachelor in
paradise and i was like
i was like
me oh my god awesome did you ever wake
up and finish it or did it i did yeah i
woke up and i finished it good good good
you did
okay that's good so like
it looks just horrid i mean and it's
like a pita
i mean look at this
chicken wednesday maybe it's five hours
old i was about to say we we yeah
reiterated that this is five years old i
warmed mine up okay i won't help you i
don't know if that's gonna help
[ __ ] wednesday night baby [ __ ]
fried chicken how much this costs
they are i think
two dollars you can get two for four
that's a pretty good deal scary cheap
bro
okay but how is it
[Music]
here we go
he's calculating
it's going for a second bite
that's what it's supposed to look like
there you go
i mean it doesn't look that far off to
be honest
it looks a little shittier
here was the other picture
[Laughter]
nasty it's five hours old
[Music]
tastes great really
it's great yeah i like it
huh nice
you were very active you were really
unimpressed with the last one that we
got where was that that
we recently did oh was it pop pop eyes
right yeah
yeah you were not happy about that one
oh i guess it was the nuggets wasn't it
how does this stack up against the
regulars chick-fil-a popeyes
i don't know i mean it's it's a
completely different
setup i don't i'm not super the popeyes
one is okay i like this one because the
bread is thin
so i like that there's more focus on the
chicken
so
how often do you eat fried chicken sam
i feel like everyone thinks i eat it so
often i really don't you really do oh
what yeah like you were eating it for
breakfast like you love fried chicken
more than anything anyone i've ever met
maybe except for gabe
right
i don't know i mean i've had these i
think this is the third time this week
honestly
i'm ashamed to admit that a lot you go
spicy or regular
i
really love the spicy chicken sandwich
from chick-fil-a
but everywhere else i usually get
regular
sam got me addicted to chick-fil-a for a
few weeks me and lena were going like
every day because we were having in the
office it's just it's too good
homophobic shit's addicting dude
definitely like the spicy one better
i feel like the bread's kind of
pointless
it's just like a pita bread
the best chicken wednesday baby
diarrhea for sure
shout out to five hour old chicken
okay
it's not bad no
my [ __ ]
this fruit flies all over this [ __ ]
right now
oh [ __ ] all right
great
fantastic nailed it i gotta be honest i
don't know what taco bell is doing
making fried chicken though seems weird
like who are they
they could talk are they taco bell's a
wild card they can they can do whatever
they want did you see there's like a big
chicken shortage because of all this
chicken sandwich craze
yeah there's an article in the daca
chicken shortage oh whoops because
everybody is
everyone's getting in on the chicken war
[ __ ] fried chicken poor chickens man
there's like a billions of chickens that
die every year it's like a full one day
ago kfc is not advertising its finger
licking good chicken tenders due to
supply shortage look at that
poultry shortage he's right eating all
the [ __ ] chickens
poor little chickies dude chicken is so
good you know the ones from costco
you know they got the best deal in town
with the rotisserie
does that scare you though that you can
go to costco buy a whole chicken's life
this chicken lived and died for 4.99
tastes so [ __ ] good 4.99 that's all
the chicken's life's worth wait really
five bucks for an entire drink that's
the costco motto because they want you
to buy more [ __ ] and they put the
chickens in the back of the store this
chicken lived and died for zach but have
are you know are you gonna say that
chicken's not good
i mean it's fine it's good chicken yeah
it's fine fantastic [ __ ] chicken
4.99 bro
i'm okay with it it's disturbing 199 to
to become this
yeah i know it's just everything yeah
somebody grew those jalapenos somebody
made the pita like there's a lot going
on shipping there's like [ __ ] the
shipping all over the country people
have to assemble it right you have to
grow the chicken you have the bread like
so many steps
they've assembled they have to package
it they have to do all these things they
have to build a whole [ __ ] building
and they're selling this [ __ ] for 199.
make that make sense to me i'm not in
the wrong though because like i'm paying
a little more for the rotisserie though
bro you're paying five dollars for like
20 times like a hundred times more
chicken yeah dude and it tastes better
in my opinion
no i'm not blaming you a lot of people
love the chicken i just find the whole
thing disturbing okay fair enough zach
how would you feel
if you got killed and someone
ate you for five bucks
i mean you're dead you're dead you know
but five bucks wouldn't you want to be
worth a little more
yeah but i'm not a [ __ ] chicken yeah
yeah good point
clock clock [ __ ]
those are good i could eat more of those
bring them out
bring out the spices and they're coming
you don't have to pause the show for
that
all right let's move on as we eat the
spices yeah
oh my god it's like a it's like a party
back here pass out the spices boys
yeah you're in the spices come on now
shredder wants a spicy yeah come on
bring it okay hey don't be cheap with me
don't be stingy
yeehaw
dan come on break your vegan [ __ ] it
i'll try it
not happening i'll take one god bless
you love get one
you ship it to sweden like three day
three day shipping it'll still be good
it'll be about as diseased as it is
right now wow
there's enough conservatives in there
that's fine
preservatives but yes
you're probably right okay and now
we're gonna be talking about my boy
my favorite public figure
you know him you love him it's harvey
weinstein oh i mean no not harvey it's
uh ryan kavanagh oh
wait is that ryan
or is that right at this point i figured
you would be able to tell the difference
they don't look
don't
okay so i think i think this is ryan
and you're learning okay so that's right
kavanaugh
he's the majority owner of triller the
company that's suing me and today i'm
happy to announce that we have filed our
motion to dismiss
let's
file our our uh anti-slap
we are coming we are coming against
yes
and we are about to
make
another fair use precedent
on matt haas 2.0
the next uh boss fight of my
career so excited
you know before we get into the motion
which
leonard french who's a copyright
attorney on youtube i'll say this
um
let me just tell you about how beautiful
this motion is now this
is leonard french a copyright attorney
he did a lot of videos about our
previous lawsuit
listen to what he had the first fair use
factor the central purpose of the first
fair use factor is to see whether and to
what extent the new work is
transformative a use is transformative
when it adds something new further
purpose different character altering the
copyrighted work with new expression
meaning or message
ninth circuit has also explained that if
the allegedly infringed work is used as
raw material transformed in the creation
of new information new aesthetics new
insights understandings this is the very
type of activity that the fair use
doctrine intends to protect for the
enrichment of society moreover the more
transformative the work the less the
significance of the other fair use
factors like commercialism that may
weigh against the finding of fair use it
is well established that among the best
recognized justifications for copying
from another's work is to provide
comment or criticism of it and they go
on to cite the matthoss case which is
just this is poetry at this point
indeed the supreme court concurs in
google a subsequent work is
transformative because it comments on
the original or criticizes it in
campbell versus a cuff rose music
comment and criticism traditionally have
had a claim to fair use protection as
transformative works for copyright geeks
this is a wet dream this is this is a
beautifully written motion to dismiss
and i i'm
as proud of it as i'm allowed to be
without sounding condescending because i
have nothing i look up to this i aspire
to this level of clarity in my law
practice
the guy
loves it and by the way matt uh the
hussein zada is the case our first fair
use lawsuit that made a case law or
precedent and so we cite it many times
in this motion which as he says is
poetry listen to how he talks about this
in the beginning
obviously the motion is very long and
legal and stuff there's a lot more
interesting stuff in the anti-slap which
i'm going to show you guys and this is
all very entertaining i promise but just
to show you what a beautiful piece of
literature of law we've written here
are we live
listen to this man
live
i'm green up there and we now have
a live connection here hello everyone
welcome good afternoon good evening good
night good morning
i'm leonard french your favorite
copyright attorney but you you could be
forgiven after this story if you want to
add a plus one to your favorite
copyright attorneys because the kleins
have hired an attorney in california who
has
filed this epic absolutely epic motion
to dismiss
really quick just a quick summary of
what eve listen to this he loves it i do
and i saw when i watch this he goes on
to explain that he is actually opposing
counsel to your lawyer in a totally
unrelated case and despite that in a
very uh classy way um says that he's so
impressed by this and that your lawyers
did an amazing job yeah my lawyers are
the brick greatest i love them this is
the same guy the same guy who worked on
my um
matt haas right and i and you know when
i first got sued i was like
the boys are back
let's get the team back together
is the lawyer who i work closely with
who wrote the debrief for the last one
and i was like i need like he just he is
so good at this [ __ ]
and uh he has delivered yet again
wow no so i know that there's a lot to
dig in here too so before we go too deep
uh we should take our break okay we'll
take a break but before we do i want to
tease you ryan cavanaugh sent me a dm on
[ __ ] instagram
it's absolutely
you may have noticed this on the wall
behind ethan oh yeah uh other side yeah
we framed his dm to me
but we'll we'll explain this when we
come back from our quick commercial
break thank you peace and love time to
take a short break thank you rudy
guys if you've been opting out of
skincare i get it i've pretty much my
whole life
not done the whole skincare thing but
since i started using curology and i did
the whole thing where i take the survey
i send the pictures i get the
dermatology recommended formula
i've got a routine
and my skin
feels
fantastic
it starts they sent me three products
they sent me the cleanser
which is super light doesn't like
destroy my skin or take all the oils off
and make it feel super dry
and then the second one is the formula
that a dermatologist puts together
special especially for your skin based
on the photos and the survey you give
them
and then third is the moisturizer
bam i do that every night and my skin
feels
like exfoliated it's glowing it's not
oily and i feel like there's certain
parts that are really clearing up and
just getting healthier um
so yeah that's what curology is they
customize a prescription formula with
three active ingredients picks for you
to help tackle your skin care needs
whether that may be trying to take
control of acne or if acne is no longer
your top skin concern fine lines dark
spots occasional breakouts or clogged
pores you start by answering questions
online about your skin and if it's a
good fit curology will match you with a
licensed dermatology provider who will
get to know your skin and subject to
consultation you'll get a customized
prescription cream to be shipped
straight to your flipping door my dudes
is awesome
i highly recommend it because you know
going to a dermatologist is a pain in
the butt it's expensive
and you're kind of getting the same
level of service here and uh
i really recommend it i've enjoyed it a
lot you can start your curology journey
just like i did with a three a free
30-day trial at curology.com h3 if
prescribed just pay five dollars for
shipping and handling that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y
dot com
h3 to unlock your free 30-day trial
please refer to our medical team uh that
is a note for me and not for you guys to
hear
thank you
that's the sound of our most beautiful
sponsor kraken friend of the show
trusted partners we love
the kraken if you're looking to get into
crypto
it's our boy
jesse powell
hey guys if you're interested investing
in cryptocurrencies but aren't sure
where to get started check out the
kraken app with kraken you can buy and
sell over 50 of the most popular cryptos
like bitcoin dogecoin and ethereum on
the go 24 7. it's super easy to get
started just download the app create
your account and you'll be investing in
minutes my dudes
one of the coolest things about buying
crypto through kraken is that you don't
need a lot of money to try it out so
even if bitcoin is worth like 40 000 you
can buy in with as little as 10 bucks
with kraken just to get your feet wet
[Music]
find out yourself why kraken has been
one of the highest rated places to buy
crypto for the last 10 years these are
pioneers trusted people we love kraken
visit kraken.com h3now to learn more or
search for kraken
in the app store we love you please
thank you
[Music]
summer is coming to an end and the
leaves are about to fall while mother
nature does her things to prepare for
the new season you can do yours by
seeing how much you could save on home
and auto insurance people
policy gene just makes it easy to
compare home and auto insurance in one
place they can help you find home and
auto coverage similar to what you have
now but at a lower price they save
customers on average one thousand two
hundred and fifty dollars per year over
what they were paying
for home and auto before they've saved
new customers on average 435 dollars per
year on auto insurance and 350 dollars
per year on home insurance
oh my god
their team will handle the paperwork to
set up your new policy or switch over
your current one here's how it works
getting starters getting started is
super easy first head on over to police
policygenius.com h3 answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property then policy genius takes it
from there they're gonna prepare raise
from america's top insurers from
progressive to allstate to find your
lowest quotes
the policy genius team can look for ways
to save you more including bundling your
home and auto policies
and if they find a better rate than what
you're paying now they'll switch you
over all for free
their top notch service has earned
policy genius thousands of five star
reviews unlike triller
across
[Music]
thousands of five star reviews across
trustpilot and google
head to
policygenius.com h3 right now to get
started policy genius it's when it comes
to insurance when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right we are back so
this is this is amazing
ryan is such an insecure douche
and go ahead you can add that to amended
complaint that i
he defamed me he called me an insecure
douche
which is basically the level of
complaints in there but anyway on on
july 11th we didn't ever even see this
and abe you alerted me to this tell me
how you found how you we figured this
out so occasionally i'll check the
podcast dms uh to see if we have any
message requests of potential guests or
interesting stories any any juice and i
was scrolling through um
and i saw a message like from back in
july from ryan cavanaugh i sent it to
you at 4 am
and said i suggest you check your dm
request as well so he had emailed us
every page of the lawsuit i was like
okay
so i went back and checked my personal
messages
and uh he also messaged me every page of
the lawsuit
and i was like hmm
i didn't see it at first i thought it
was the same thing but i went up all the
way and i was like holy [ __ ] ryan sent
me a direct message on july 11th
listen to this ship
ethan
i am not sure why you have decided to
take it upon yourself and your show to
malign attack
slander and defame me
i do not know you
i also don't know why you are spending
thousands i dollars
to have thousands of dummy accounts post
fake statements about me
on my instagram
and tens of thousands
to have fake app store reviews of
triller
worst yet
you have dedicated and entire show of
yours reading your own fake reviews
while amusing
and slightly annoying at best
i would advise you stop
and mitigate your damage now
your toy podcast seems fun and all
but this is real business with real
consequences and you are causing real
damage
clearly you are a very unhappy and
disturbed human
to take it upon yourself to attack
someone you don't know with false and
misleading information
especially to spend tens of thousands of
dollars on it
but it must stop
you have been warned
and i will not
be threatened
and maligned and stand by idly
govern yourself accordingly sir
right cavanaugh
this dude really thinks he's like a
movie super villain he thinks he's don
corleone seriously bro you ain't do you
ain't [ __ ] bro you just don't you're
just like a professional bankrupter
i mean i'm assuming he really thought he
would scare me
yeah maybe if he had somebody proofread
it a little bit
yeah all that all the typos and
grammatical errors kind of takes the
window to the sales a little bit like oh
yeah ryan that's really good it could
have been written by keem from by
keemstar and i would have uh
not blinked
i love that he thinks that you're
spending tens of thousands of dollars to
malign him on the app store and stuff
yeah we got to break this down a little
bit let's see and it was used in a book
huh
[Applause]
let's see he accused me of spending
thousands of dollars to post dummy
accounts fake statements about me on
instagram and i'm sorry dude like that
[ __ ] was free this
i didn't i'm not doing anything
what are you talking about
i mean i have a pot i have i have
huh
i'm sorry that sounds to me like slander
what [ __ ] proof do you have huh
i have hired and by the way self-report
you seem to know a lot about hiring and
the cost of having fake dummy accounts
mr ryan bitch-ass kavanaugh indeed
indeed which maybe will reveal some more
information about that
we may we may have some information
about that actually but maybe
we have enough to talk about today
already so projection and confession
i have never hired a single dummy
account i am a dummy
and i left a review so i am i guess
there's one dummy account me yep
but i'm sorry if people don't like your
app those aren't fake statements bro
your app sucks it's flipped your own guy
said it
because you're reading your own fake
reviews okay sick weirdo i would never
do that ugh it's all flipped and then he
says clearly i'm a very unhappy and
disturbed human
excuse me
huh
i don't have two dui's
and uh i am not being sued by my nanny
and i have never lied under oath [ __ ]
ass
what's this headline here
deadline
relativity fabricated memo claiming
sexual harassment against former
co-president adam fields judge awards
8.4 million what was the name on that
edited uh that forged memo who was it
last edited by
cav
fraud
well john cav jaw rule would call it
that
we're not making a judgment statement
rule calls it fraud yeah
that's raw that's fraud john rule knows
a lot about the topic
john roll doesn't speak for us of course
jarrow speaks for himself and his views
do not uh represent that of the h3
podcast
uh you have been warned sir threat
govern yourself accordingly well i did
and i said [ __ ] you sue me [ __ ]
you are nothing to me except the giant
douche trying to censor my free speech
you should govern yourself accordingly
douche [ __ ]
like i'm sorry
the guy doesn't know anything this was a
comment
under leonard french's uh video that i
thought was pretty was pretty good um
here this was two comments back to back
in his
in his chat it said h3 and their lawyers
just casually reminding the world that
they literally set the modern precedent
for fair use yeah i think you should do
a little [ __ ] research we'll try to
bully people douche
of all people why would they go after
someone who defined copyright law of
reaction videos
good question
they're happy to do it again they
probably just didn't know
like what they were stepping into they
didn't they didn't do their research on
you look back then i was broke now i'm
[ __ ] rich let's be honest yeah the
costs of this lawsuit you literally have
[ __ ] you money and you're using it yeah
well and even i'm happy to send that
precedent so yeah [ __ ] you
i mean at this point with the way the
trailer's hemorrhaging money i might
even be richer than ryan cavanaugh
i definitely will be by the time trailer
goes bankrupt
so anyway
oh there's some other great ones uh this
is stuff i've been waiting to show and
now that everything's filed i can show
it
look at this
now when they first started threatening
us and stuff they asked for a million
dollars they said that uh we had caused
50 million damages and all this insane
[ __ ] so we
in an act of absolute
generosity
magnanimously
to just make this go away
to not have stress
to be you know make every uh fair u a a
good faith effort to resolve this effort
amicably
instead of having to waste a judge in
court's time we offered him 25 000
not a small amount of money
no
and so it's probably like half of his
net worth yeah at this point
for sure
and so you know i didn't even want to do
that but uh i think we considered with
our lawyers and everything we're like
this would better we'd be happier for
this just to go away you know either was
he was pregnant and there's just a lot
of we're like okay of course it sucks
but yeah i mean
it's easier than doing a lawsuit
for me i was always very gung-ho like
okay i'm not going to be silenced this
is fair [ __ ] use [ __ ] like i just i'm
ready to go dude when it comes to this
[ __ ]
uh but anyway so we offered that in good
faith and they countered with they said
no we need 900 dollars
and they needed us to make the following
statement you ready
they wanted me to say this publicly so i
guess i am doing that for them
but here it is verbatim
we are pleased to announce
that we have reached a settlement with
trailer fight club
as a result of us pirating the event
triller surprisingly has embedded
watermark technology unlike anything
we've seen to date
we had to pay millions to settle
in order to avoid 50 million or more in
potential
liability we encourage anyone who
pirated the event
to take
triller's amnesty offer very seriously
and pay the fifty dollars before what
happens to us
happens to you
triller is incredibly serious about this
and we do believe they will find most
if not all people who pirated this is so
[ __ ] unhinged this is one of the
craziest things i've ever seen they so
like not only not only 900 000 but they
also wanted me to read this hack [ __ ]
insane
to lie for them so basically lying about
how much i paid them yes
lying that people are that they're
hunting everyone down right um this is
insane oh surprising watermark
technology shut the [ __ ] up unlike
anything you've ever seen before can you
imagine
imagine ethan
reading that
unironically like just try to imagine
evil it just goes with the
touch they are
they didn't know who they were
they didn't to be honest
yeah so this is kavkav coming after me
so basically at one point we said you
know what uh
[ __ ] this it's so nice that we can
finally reveal this because i feel like
there's an uh
a small but significant proportion of
the audience that has
questioned
whether you know you were maybe being a
little petty with the way that you were
dealing with and everything and now that
this is out like people in in plain view
people can see just like what a [ __ ]
douche this guy is like
thank you
that that's a good point to say because
like at first we really tried our best
and you remember i was like i'm gonna
hold my tongue yeah you weren't saying
[ __ ] at first good faith uh mediation
right we want to resolve this and i feel
like we made we made a a pretty fair
offer consider them 25 000 for doing
nothing wrong to just you're like all
right let's just drop this issue that's
more than fair no thing
yeah but like the statement alone like
if they said no payment and read the
statement i would have said go [ __ ]
yourself obviously you know what i mean
yeah
um
no the the lawyers and ryan uh the
lawyers representing ryan have been
nothing
but uh just
unprofessional belligerent
and uh absolutely uh
unworkable you know what i mean yeah
it's mad house 2.0
it really is
to count like
to counter offer with 900 000 like you
know this still would have been douchey
but if they had come back and said like
no we want a hundred thousand you know
four times what you offered or whatever
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't have paid
them that much right but like but like
at least like be realistic yeah it's
like within the realm of possibility
maybe that like you you lowball at first
they highball and then you work
something out but like and insanely a
million dollars almost they want coupled
with a statement that i could never
could never i could never utter yeah
triller surprisingly
has embedded in watermark technology
unlike anything we've ever seen
yeah don't worry trillo i'm not sure
anyone's even concerned about
bootlegging your [ __ ] events uh it's all
flipped
oh man
yeah [ __ ] you chiller
so
this has been filed
the anti-slap is filed
and here i want to
show some of my favorite moments
from the anti-slap
now an anti-slap is so the motion
dismissed is basically for the copper
infringement all that [ __ ] but they sued
me twice i don't know if you knew this
for tortoise interference
which is some really dumb [ __ ] they're
saying that we caused them to interfere
with their business with fake reviews
which excuse me dude i'd like to see
some evidence for that
and in california they have a law
the anti-slap
it stands for um
strategic lawsuit against public
participation so if there's um if
there's
public interest involved if and
generally these lawsuits are to chill
people from talking about them then the
anti-slap can be used to strike down the
lawsuit and also force
ryan to pay for our legal fees straight
up
so yeah the anti-slaps here to read it
uh specifically is intended to prevent
people from using courts and potential
threats of a lawsuit to intimidate
people who are exercising the first
amendment rights literally me thank you
california
so we're using the anti-slap to address
the interference one
here's the intro to the anti-slap here
free speech for me
but not for thee
this is the theme
relentlessly campaigned by plaintiff
triller and its majority owner ryan
kavanagh to harass punish and silence
defendants for exercising the first
amendment rights triller and kavanaugh
have repeatedly abused the judicial
system to silence commentary and
criticism made about them on the podcast
this assault on defendant's lawful
criticism began by trailer and kavanaugh
causing triller subsistence subsistence
subsidiary subsidiary subsidiary
chiller fight club 2 to sue defendants
for copyright infringement for the use
of a short clip of jake paul vs ben
askren
for commentary on criticism trailer and
kavanaugh are now suing defendant for
the lawful speech
criticizing
the copyright action triller and
kavanaugh so let me read that's the
intro
let me read you some juicy morsels in
here
hit me with them morsels
oh is this the same it is the same link
okay
here's a section uh there's this part
section in in uh motions for
statement of facts
so here's the statement of facts for
ryan cavanaugh the public figure
statement of facts
kavanaugh is the majority owner of
trailer
kavanaugh was the former ceo of
relativity media at relativity this is
an old version so if you see that it's
not cited and stuff then that's why
but in the final version there's all
uh more citations it's all cited and
stuff got you
yeah
comes the majority of trailer kavanaugh
was the former ceo of relativity media
at relativity kavanaugh drove the
company into bankruptcy twice
statement of fact
by the second bankruptcy relativity had
approximately 30 million dollars in
assets and nearly 600 million dollars of
liabilities
i'm not i mean i'm i'm more of a
uh more of an asset guy
yeah i mean i i'm not like a big time
entrepreneur but i know that's that's
not good
despite relative relativity's insolvency
kavanaugh made relativity pay him a two
and a half million dollar consulting fee
sketchy
in an arbitration the honorable terry
friedman
found that kavanaugh fabricated a memo
alleging sexual harassment against the
former president of relativity adam
fields statement of fact
in the same arbitration kavanaugh
falsely testified under oath
that the memo was authored by former
in-house counsel at relativity
in retaliation for exposing his false
testimony kavanaugh sued mr fields
damn that's all statement of fact huh
kavanaugh has been embroiled in several
other public controversies for example
kavanaugh's nanny was forced to sue
kavanaugh because he refused to pay her
fax
um and an executed verified complaint
drafted by
this lawyer uh and covered by the press
cavanaugh's former business partner elon
spar accused kavanaugh's new business
venture approx proxima media being a
ponzi scheme
where have i heard about that before
this was written by by variety
oh
right gene mattis in variety magazine
the trade paper the industry trade paper
very reputable right statement of fact
kavanaugh also received two arrests and
a conviction for driving under the
influence facts
kavanaugh's controversies have resulted
in being shunned by hollywood the ceo of
stalsis media described kavanaugh best
each time someone lies at cans ryan
cavanaugh gets a royalty
that's true
that's quite the burn
those are all that's just a background
there a little background
on ryan
uh here is some of the this is like the
defamation stuff
all right so here is their first claim
of defamation
they say i apparently i said triller is
and mr cavanaugh runs a ponzi scheme
which of course i never said obviously
so we said this statement failed i said
he did i mean i never said he runs up i
mean variety
wrote an article about it
uh
yeah
the trailer is uh this statement fails
to meet the first amendment requirement
for defamation foremost this statement
was never said in the podcast
rather examining each of the podcasts as
a whole it is apparent that the podcast
accurately discussed the situation
mr sparr made in his 2019 verified
complaint against kavanaugh and proxima
media
therefore trailer cannot show that this
statement was ever made
let alone that it was even false
right
um this is a great one this is
defamation apparently triller falsely
presented that comedian kevin hart uses
the app
that's defamation listen to this
this statement is true because when the
podcast aired triller's description for
the app stated that millions have made
trailer videos alongside huge global
stars such as kevin hart despite kevin
hart having no presence on the app
indeed triller effectively concedes this
point by removing mr hart's name from
the trailer's app description
after filing this lawsuit therefore this
statement is not actionable
ugh it's so awkward just search kevin
hart on triller and prove me wrong
oh this is probably the most damage oh
my god this is the one we're most
worried about
me and and my attorneys were we we had
a lot of deep conversations about how
we're going to fight this one
of course the most damning evidence the
app is flipped
defamatory statement this statement was
originally made by mr beck a prominent
social media personality as he was
creating a video using the trailer app
client uh in the video mr beck stated yo
triller my thing is flipped
yo triller my thing's flipped because he
was experiencing issues with the
triller's app camera function therefore
insofar as this statement contains an
assert an assertion of facts it is true
and not actionable trailer your thing is
quite clearly flipped
oh it's all flipped
this one is tough too i don't know how
we're going to beat this one mr
kavanaugh bears a physical resemblance
to harvey weinstein
defamatory to have an opinion on
someone's opinion here if beauty is in
the eye of the beholder the same holds
true for the lack thereof
now
uh you know
basically what's his complaint that
harvey weinstein's ugly
and that he thinks he's beautiful you
know like what's defamatory or like
what's the complaint what's wrong with
how harvey weinstein looks
you fat shaming
you know i mean this is friend right you
already talking about his friend like
yeah hey come on
but you should be happy to be compared
physically to him this statement
constitutes a non-actual opinion because
express the subjective perception that
kavanaugh looks like weinstein
in which some h3 podcast members agree
and some disagree it's very true i
disagree strongly further this statement
is of concerning kavanaugh and not
triller
not actionable
i happen to think he looks just like
harvey weinstein but dan to this day
still says i don't see it i don't see it
even a little bit i literally can't even
tell the difference
like is that ryan
we went over this earlier in the episode
i i thought we i thought we made this
clear it's just so confusing
i tend to just look at the shirt color
that's how i remember show me uh
ian
so this is ryan in the black shirt
uh
uh no no no the blue shirt wait yeah the
blue shirt i look at both photos the one
in the other corner where he's wearing
blue that's how i figure it out
oh you do you have to do a mat like okay
so here's ryan oh same outfit yeah okay
exactly that's how ultimately i that's
pretty smart yeah it's that uncanny it's
a pretty smart way to
decode that yeah i can't tell the
difference to be honest
it's called uh pros uh pro
prosopagnosia by the way i think you
might have that where uh people it's a
disorder where you face blindness you
can't uh you think i'm face flying if
you think right they look like they look
similar how are you gonna accuse me of
being face blind bruh
everyone on the crew says they see the
resemblance
you might be the one that's facing no i
think pro
supergnosia might be uh uh contagious
oh yeah i think you might have given it
to everybody i i'm immune personally all
right
do you see it
and then his f his final
claim is that mr kavanaugh is suing the
defendants
he goes i'm not suing the defendants
it's triller the company that i own the
majority of this statement is
substantially true triller's counsel
told defendants that kavanaugh was
behind the lawsuit one
further illustrating
let me get this straight he's suing you
for defamation for saying
that he's suing you yes
well that is his argument is that i'm
not suing you
triller my company that i owner
is suing you
and that's defamation
jesus
yeah it's embarrassing that they even
wrote this so is that one so so is the
defamation lawsuit him personally like
are there yes okay so triller and
kavanaugh so he is suing he
but only after you said that he was
suing exactly okay got it
throw the book at him boys
triller's counsel told us that kavanaugh
was behind the copyright action that's
how we even learned about him
right they're trying to scare us like
ryan cavanaugh's behind it you don't
want to [ __ ] with this guy
oops and i was like who the [ __ ] is this
get better lawyers ryan and then further
further illustrating kavanaugh's
involvement are the first amended
complaint numerous mentions of
allegations of false misleading and
malicious statements concerning
kavanaugh wow why do you care and not
trailer interesting
trailers council sending kavanaugh's
retraction letter
and
that kavanaugh is the majority owner of
trailer and subsist
subsidiaries thank you
further this statement is of a
concerning kavanaugh and not triller
finally even assuming arguiendo
that this statement is false triller
cannot
prove actual mouse because triller led
defendants believe kavanaugh was behind
the copyright action and personal action
anyway it's all up there and it's been a
lot of fun so
thank you uh thank you thank you
for the opportunity to prove fair use
again in court and we have immortalized
your absolutely um terrifying message
it's a little obscured
it's absolutely
shaking in my boots
govern yourself accordingly sir
and our toy podcast our toy i was just
about to point that part out how dare
you sir this is not a toy this is
anything but a toy
serious business here i was thinking
maybe good merch could be like toy
podcast ryan kavanagh something
my toy podcast
[Music]
you know yeah i know
all right you guys want to do the cursed
tick tocks
sure
bro we can't play it it's cursed
dee are you logged into all of our
accounts already uh i am i i have to go
one by one because i can only be logged
in to one at a time on desktop but let
me set this up as you yeah yeah
prepare
so once again
we have spent
a week making our tick tock feed as
cursed as possible
we started with fresh accounts and the
rules were that you could only like
videos
you couldn't follow hashtags
or uh
so basically you can't cheat you had to
do it organically yeah organic yeah yeah
so i'm very curious who would you like
to begin with since we have to go one by
one well
cameron's kind of been pushing this so
maybe let's start with cam's because
he's i feel like he's gonna have the
best one maybe save that for last okay
well dan you've been crying about your
no but let's start strong let's get
people interested okay so the rule is
you get 10 swipes right 10 swipes
and then at the end we can vote amongst
ourselves whose is the most cursed feed
right correct okay
all right so here's cameron's so right
off the bat doesn't seem that cursed i
got to be honest we got a 600 000
like video of a guy just
i don't get this one at all like yeah
and actually i don't even know why so
many people liked it yeah yeah do we
have the potential to read the comments
and get some insight well
unk off the perks again who who's who
uncle
bestie throwing
them one-on-one one's only got them
megan knees
bruh i don't even know what these are
insane
too out of the loop for this one all
right now all right let's move on we got
some minion vibes
it's pretty good
yeah it's okay it's pretty good okay
over saturated it's not the best i'm not
actually too impressed with uh my fresh
my fresh yeah because you're you're like
actual you are the king of this [ __ ] you
can't uh cam's actual tick tock is is
unbelievably cursed right so
you know well but that's okay all right
okay
so we got well this one's
i mean it's i'm i'm enjoying it
she's having a good old time she's
dancing what is she bopping to
team prez productions team prez
productions here bring it up for just a
second zach
yeah hit it hit us with it
school taste
okay turn it down she's she's bogeying
all right she's doing an awesome song
okay oh here we go all right here we go
looking for single ladies am i
attractive
[Music]
that guy's beautiful oh i love the
filters he's hot as hell
he's as hot as his
guy for real or is this
i'm interested i'm would like to know
more so this is a good one okay all
right you got a good one
okay this is interesting
[Music]
so it's a whole it's a dude with a
sideshow bobcat
it's pretty interesting i've never seen
anyone look like that before
comments are
off oh
what a shame
well he's feeling himself i'm a fan yeah
i'm interested all right and uh oh this
this seems good pull my finger
excuse me
good morning america
that's pretty good okay
that was a good one
and i think this is our 10th here we go
pov your name is anthony
uh this one
is
cam i gotta say i'm a little let down
i'm a little late i really thought you
were gonna bring the heat i gotta say i
feel the same this is not this is not my
age did you expect kind of a more uh
dynamic page or is this kind of how it's
been for you i'm wondering if uh because
it's on
on the web on the desktop version if
it's any different because of that but
no remains to be seen
okay well try mine because i'm pretty
confident that mine is kind of more or
less where i want it to be okay well
let's see i'm going to take a little bit
of a different theory there
really you think it's different
i think so yeah i don't think so because
i logged into mine uh
when testing this morning and um and it
was we'll see just as [ __ ] up as my uh
mine i took a little bit of a different
route okay there was a specific niche
that i kind of went down the rabbit hole
on
and um i'm hoping oh i'm liking what i'm
saying already all right so here's
ethan's first
yeah so all right it's
just having fun
it's yeah so the theme that i went for
was like mega uh thirst traps oh okay i
love that really interesting i found a
lot of interesting stuff but i love it
so yeah there's that's a pretty good one
yeah all right starting out strong
here's number two oh see this is great
stuff
nicolette
[Music]
no she she said she'd pick me up at
four
okay yeah all right
oh wait forget aim dude yeah
oh no oh
hashtag dad bod hashtag
he's got a good vibe i don't know why
i'm getting two of him i wanted more
uh i wanted more yeah more variety all
righty but hopefully that's only the
second one we see all right well moving
on to number four my family in irvington
alabama
they gave me the name big booger double
off get down and they're going to help
me get a car
well
alabama
i'm totally new to tick-tock like i
don't use tik-tok on a regular basis at
all we don't need to hear that exactly
yeah please thank you
um manly call me big bugaloo bug then
they're buying me a new car this is the
original sound co-international wolf
pack lee
durr i assume was the rest of that
statement but ran out of space or
something so that's four right that's
four yeah moving on we got wait what see
i'm not i don't know why i'm getting the
same people but okay let's hear it me
and ashley i'm not mad about it we're
fine together
and if you do
i report y'all
for harassment
one more time this menu skull guy demon
king
it's very reminiscent of ryan
kavanaugh's dm
that's that's actually might be what
ryan cavanaugh looks like after this
lawsuit's over oh no
there's a resemblance
all right so that was five here's six
oh yeah so me loves me oh yes
yeah loving that filter kind of a mega
thirst strap but to become more of a
country dude what a mane this guy has he
looks like a sexy raiden
he's a wizard for sure he looks like he
is for sure a wizard oh man interesting
really really digging that one
all right here's seven so my account my
other account
i know i did like a short video on it
but it's gonna be up like in four days i
just uh
it just
pisses me off that people want to report
instead of block you if they don't like
your [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] block button for a
reason you'll never see the [ __ ] again
ever
the fact that you want to take somebody
down because of how many followers they
have
you're a piece of [ __ ]
facts hell i'd i'd be happy with 10. i
love it as long as they actually watch
my [ __ ] and i watch their [ __ ] and we
get along we have [ __ ] fun that's
what this app is about that isn't about
oh god damn i got a big [ __ ]
following account i'm [ __ ] huge
never been about that
so if you don't like somebody's content
hit the block button
they'll be a little worm you know what i
mean
definitely [ __ ] man-hating [ __ ]
hoe oh wow like serious come on now that
took a turn by the way by the way a lot
of people the arch on his brim is super
impressive that's like a half circle
straight up
i know 180 degrees great observation
yeah yeah
pretty good i mean that's pretty good
that guy could be greg paul's brother
oh
uncle paul yeah uncle paul
that is he's got paul family live don't
let uncle paul near the team 10 house
and be wrong please please don't all
right next all right we got left eight
okay i'll tell you something buddy okay
this is not a dump to me okay in your
opinion doesn't give one hoots and a
holler you understand me
at least i have a pot to piss in and a
window to throw it out of and a roof
over my [ __ ] head you probably still
in the basement with your mama and you
50 years old
and you're gonna come on here and make
comments about somebody's home
well
you're about an idiot
that's what you are so the comment says
you work and drive trucks
you were asking for
you would know why i was asking for
money
asking for money
[Music]
here we go come on guys i think i did
pretty good you have done very well
these have all been bangers for the most
part yeah this is some granny and
underwear just putting on a show myself
oh yeah talk to me baby
age is just a number
but
in the opposite way of what r kelly
intended yeah of course yeah okay
and finally we have
archer williams
[Music]
dude i gotta say
that i'm pretty impressed with uh that
was a solid shot
yeah well done there was it's weird
because it like started with total
cowboy thirst traps like a lot of dudes
and jeans who are shirtless dancing and
i don't know how it devolved into
whatever that was but i'm happy that it
did
what's impressive is you had a very
specific
niche that you went for and it reflected
in the book thank you yeah no it's it's
incredible if you just go back to my
page and just scroll scroll scroll
you'll see it's all country [ __ ] like
they nailed it yeah like just give it a
good scroll dan oh i already logged out
all right but yeah it's all country [ __ ]
so that was fun for me i i'm glad i i
picked uh a niche
maybe that was a good strategy i'll talk
about mine when i get to it but i really
struggle with this assignment like i
said i am not a tick-tock user and um
and yeah this was this was difficult
well why don't you go dan let's see i
just logged into abs uh a b how you
feeling
i i think something went wrong with that
something went very wrong with that
i think
okay
there's you're going to quickly notice
a theme with abs
asian women
well not asian i've already noticed that
what's going on with this a b
not asian all right go ahead let's not
throw it all right here's number two
[Music]
here's number three okay baby what the
[ __ ]
yeah
no get that that girl's
i can't tell how old she is but
amy what are you doing dude all right oh
okay oh it's a little tj wait are they
really wait they're like really fighting
all right i'm gonna move on what is
going
move on all right oh this woman's
breastfeeding come on get that
get it out of the screen
did you show that i don't know i don't
know if he enjoyed it for like half a
second we'll have to cut we generally
need to edit or all
what the [ __ ] what have you been doing
you've been drifting off on tick tock
so first i didn't know that we were
supposed to
like we could like stuff i thought it
was just based on what we watched like
watch time
and last night it was like really skewed
uh
i don't know i woke up this morning and
it was just all
this
dude
all right you were jerking off all night
all right here's uh
this was six this girl um
not on robin that sounded like a yoko
sound bite almost
it was uh here's number seven oh here's
a little variety yeah bro you didn't
even this is like straight like normies
paid [ __ ]
this is weak this is normie i did
i did see this one uh last night yeah
when i was uh we got the biggest
reaction out of mine so far though so
that's true i don't know yeah that's
true number eight breastfeeding okay
this is so normie get the [ __ ] out of
here it's one of 17 million 19 million
likes what the hell yeah
i don't think i've like never seen a
video with that many likes before
i saw quite a few last night when it's
on the fresh account like you said it
shows all the normy stuff and uh yeah it
was getting all a lot of this kind of
crap all right couple more hey y'all it
is fish fry friday let's get some
catfish but uh just in case you didn't
notice these baby girls i have a theory
that here's another if you have multiple
accounts on the same phone they somehow
bro i have two accounts i have three
accounts on my phone and i don't see any
mega thirst straps oh and this is the uh
the um scarlett johansson wannabe that i
saw like ten thousand times
what makes me think that is look at cams
cam is the master but his was pretty
vanilla compared to his youtube i have
three accounts
yeah but you also i'm sure you watch a
lot of like crazy right wing
no there's no mega thursday sounds like
excuses
and regardless i mean what are you
saying that you have you have
breastfeeding videos yeah your normal
account has breastfeeding videos you
know
there's like this middle ground that it
combines
what's the middle ground between your
page and breastfeeding
sleeping on the couch
another thirst trap maybe this is i
don't think we can continue to watch
this
and here's the video of them ending the
marines ending in the marines
awesome yeah baby
oh america [ __ ] rules oh
all right
it's a girl in a really tight dress
shaking that ass
all right so yeah we get the idea this
is abs
amy what the hell is this
it was actually
it's funny
it was actually worse
that was interesting come back oh it did
it disappeared to his house it
disappeared oh here we go wait oh yeah
what the
hell
tell me you've got a real car
yeah all right
all right
did you spend a lot of time on this baby
or i mean it's fine you've been busy i'm
not going to judge you yeah i didn't
spend a lot of time on it it's a big
investment to get it right i spent a few
hours for sure scrolling over the course
of the week
it was mainly yesterday to be honest but
i go for blondes or brunettes i go for
anyone who'll go for me
yeah i spent basically any time i was on
the john i was just spending like a good
ten minutes scrolling oh there you go
you know ethan i think my um
for you paige i think it might compete
with yours okay exciting yeah uh zach's
did uh turn out pretty [ __ ] cursed so
here's this is good right now this is
zach's 600 likes yeah if i was a batman
i'd bet on zach to win
okay
all right so yeah i mean not a bad start
and it's just here we go
good morning to talk to mama
what am i
muted what am i looking at that's a man
with a piece of luck
is that his belly yeah yeah it is
that's a kenneth lee anderson
you know the man the reverend kenneth
lee anderson the reverend kevin oh
reverend kenneth i know wow
so yeah
this is good this is good stuff i i'm
yeah i guess that's his stomach there's
just something about it just it's
definitely it's very badly he's tripping
me out you can click his page if you
want more details no you could see his
titty under his uh elbow right no you're
right it's just it's a very odd shape
well because he's kind of skinny on the
top i guess that's what was throwing me
off is he doesn't look that large
anywhere but the belt his shoulders and
face look like
normal right is he wearing like a tank
top
is it covered in fabric i think it's
yeah that's what was tripping me out yes
exactly okay well very so far i'm still
good over here here's number four what
dude what yeah zach this is that boy all
right well let me watch it [ __ ] johnny
you're [ __ ]
you're so awesome man i'm glad you are
my
boy you're [ __ ] honestly sweet donny
don't go too far my boy too fast okay
hang on
that's great donnie
you're doing [ __ ] awesome boy what a
ledge
hang on buddy
hang on bro
hang on buddy
i have no recollection of ever liking a
video like this
hang on what is it that's what they all
say [ __ ] you're awesome
donnie the legend dude
damn
gosh i wonder i wonder
that doesn't reach ten thousand well i
don't know oh man that was [ __ ]
reached way past ten thousand oh is that
a milly i will say that's one thing i
like about tick tock they're very like i
feel like the comment section is a lot
more respectful and uh maybe
not on my page
not like your post specifically people
responding to you
but yeah i know what you mean like
because this is inspiring
it's cool everyone's probably really
supportive in the comments mm-hmm
wait go back up i'm just i'm really
curious you want to test that theory
yeah go ahead i'm telling you it's it's
going to be kind
bro is stuck in a permanent whip yes not
so much i say
that's the top
keep clicking titties ignore the hate
okay so that's good exactly
wait no go back to the comments let's
let's test davey's theory here okay
great johnny
buzz i'm trying how many of those
comments did you leave baby
[Laughter]
how many did you leave ethan you cynic
i'm just saying we went there looking
for kindness and it was all i'm just
saying in general usually
and tick tock anytime someone has a
disability or something along those
lines that the comments are very kind
and they they have a lot of likes and
people are very supportive unlike on
youtube sounds like a fantastic world
you're living in
i'm just saying people were obscene
maybe my feet is all kind people maybe
that's true
to back him up i have seen a lot of
positivity on post like that i think
this is just a one-off okay fair enough
i hope so
because i mean you know it takes bravery
to put yourself out there absolutely
let's try uh
let's see what harmony is all about
lemon cake
sheila e would make prince lemon cake
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sex addict at 55 and menopausal
oh my goodness talk about too much info
let's let's just chill let's go to the
comments on this one and test davey's
theory an older man's dream okay so
there's some thirst trapping older than
55 certainly that's not very nice
i'm 54 and right there with you hey
you're looking for some let's see what
franklin fisher's about real quick oh
yeah that's not good yeah frankly
10k oh no i kind of [ __ ] it up by
going on that it like refreshed the feed
well i guess it doesn't really matter
we'll just go all right so this is seven
this is the seventh video
[Music]
like
good afternoon keep passing me
it's hot good afternoon to you good
morning to me it's a very cheery caption
for what seems to be a very sad video
well she she's just or
she's just lip-syncing so it's not
really oh she's the lipstick
keep pissing me yeah okay okay
number eight
oh yeah nice guys [ __ ] well john
fogarty
can you zoom a little bit dan just
get some more
some a little closer on that so this is
vampira and uh blood
and they these guys um they actually
fanned me
they're made-ups where are they based
out of i think uh arlington
are they big show-ups
pardon me do a lot of people show up i
do a lot of people i don't know i've
just seen on their page they have uh
well they have um 260 000 followers so
18 plus only damn oh no 18 plus only oh
really i also think it's funny that the
john yogurt is not playing right now
right
i like the couple i'm into them yeah
do you want to see some of their 18 plus
content no okay they're a hoot man
they're ooh all right here's number nine
morgan
oh oh
she got no teeth just stuck that in
there
oh she just she's just showing her
process of getting ready which includes
putting in the dentures
there you go i personally wouldn't
that's a blow-up from beginning of this
video to the end i gotta say
yeah there are a lot of
tick tocks of people who put in dentures
and then get ready i think i follow one
if i'm being honest is there actually i
think there's just a lot of people more
people that have dentures and fake teeth
than we know of yeah i guess i mean how
would you know a lot of the time right i
mean they look amazing like people with
denture teeth
genuinely they look better than mine
right her teeth look perfectly better
than mine i think you could order them
just straight off amazon well maybe i
should just get dentures you think so no
it's a lot easier than fixing my job you
need to fit them yeah over existing
teeth
yeah i think you might look like freddie
mercury but
you sell them i don't know if that's
right those are fitted those look good
yeah all right this is the last one
number ten keep america great let's go
it's no big secret that i look a little
different than most because of my eyes
hashtag blind
okay
um great
okay
and love the maga hat very cool oh wait
keep america great not make america
great again
i think that's actually like a that's a
counter to uh no i think that's trump's
like running again oh
okay yeah i guess that would make sense
too all right well that's zach's and
certainly a front-runner at this point i
would say for what level of curse you
think that was better than mine
and love says yeah and what do you think
you love well
okay i'll give it to zach it was good
i'm gonna vote ethan
okay ian's got your back i mean
[Applause]
i didn't have any breastfeeding i
thought ethan's was a little more
consistent
zach had some standouts but yours was
like
that's very kind very diplomatic well
reason
maybe you look like you have some
thoughts
say what you want what you gotta be say
what you want don't be like don't be
lazy i i
i in terms of what we were going for i
think zax was [ __ ]
oh that was hard for him thank you wow
i mean years were good but they're like
stuff we'd show on like after dark i
feel like you know just
okay
nothing it's not personal qab
business
you're the master what do you think
that's true you are the master thank you
thank you
well get
give him the microphone
i think uh actually as far as curse goes
i'd go
probably ethan right now [ __ ] you i'm
sorry man i i got an idea this is
closely divided because
yeah it was more focused than i
i got i feel like i could couldn't watch
ethan's more than i could watch actually
i don't know
i'm gonna it's a toss-up for me
stick with ethan okay i respect it yeah
always good job though zach i mean you
took the assignment uh very seriously so
i just opened mine and the first one is
this girl again i got the same lady
sex addict at 55 and menopause and it
doesn't have that many likes too so tick
tock knows
there's like a we must be yeah we're
that's my name i think i gotta go off
cam and abs theory that i feel like the
web is different
it's not just that is that the multiple
accounts on the same device i feel like
has some kind of like or maybe she's
just nearby
or maybe she's just nearby
that is also a good point love all right
so here's the second one for me he's
fresh this is okay it's good yeah this i
like so yeah i was um really struggling
with this assignment i strolled for like
an hour and a half last night and was
just nothing but normie [ __ ]
and after
a lot of hard work i woke up this
morning and i i feel like the algorithm
ticks over
after a few hours or something because
all of a sudden today my [ __ ] is super
[ __ ] so this is great so yeah we got
we got some some weird little dancing
this is prime first right here yeah it's
really good this is deep tik tok 2021 i
think i followed that one we were
allowed to follow people right if you
organically found them because i i did
follow a lot of accounts go ahead all
right here's number
three you just got spongebob
now go spongebob someone else lmao
that's pretty normal i mean it's kind of
cursed at the same time because it's
just so kind of shitty
yeah of course
i don't know damn well this bathroom
smells like
but
what is buddha here
you know what beduci is i really don't
don't pretend like you don't know a bad
i've heard of of of bussy
i'm stroking [ __ ] down here but what's
badousy i i don't know you don't know no
i have no idea anybody know
nobody wants to chime in okay nobody
wants to admit they know what it is
next
[Music]
bro they were getting business done text
me one two three for the link wait what
the [ __ ]
i don't have any idea what the [ __ ]
we're looking at right now
what's the comments it seems to be in
i mean
something is going on
oh okay this is just some weird thing
where they say ah this is some weird
[ __ ] bro i don't know not into it
yeah i don't know i do not know what
this is okay here we go
i think i followed this guy
santa i was seeing him a lot
so this is uh this is number six okay
just hit the most absolutely
un
despicable lick
like it's like
i don't get it minus has been very
confusing so far i don't know what is
that i don't even know what most of
these are
my whole for you page is that a foot is
that a locker i liked one bro i liked
one video
this is weird i liked one video this
morning and now it's taking over
literally what
okay
is this a reference to like
his dog looking his wiener or something
oh no
i hope not wait click hit a lick that's
a hashtag let's just see where this
takes oh boy here we go
okay so no this isn't animal related
well hmm
italic is just uh
a robbery
oh yeah the guy hit a leg
did he steal it
okay whatever moving on why is this
chick back you went back to the top you
refresh
here let me do this there we go
[Music]
seven
pain pain talk i swear in my life i
always try sigh
better luck next time what
this is just like depressed talk
oh it's just the
wow it's just rain outside the window
okay okay all jokes aside dana are you
okay
hashtag pain you know it it i'm actually
surprised as the first one of these that
came up because this is this morning it
was like all people that were depressed
and super sad like that was my entire
page for some reason so
this looks like this might be another
one
i wish she could see how pretty she is
whenever she talks about something she
doesn't like about herself it makes me
want to give her a hug this is just sad
talk bro i got onto sad talk somehow
god damn it it is impressive somebody's
sobbing so bad just scroll all this [ __ ]
all right next
um
watch this video at least once a day
oh that is bo burnham holy [ __ ] okay not
that cursed
let's argue what was the best flavor
arguing about ramen wow so i mean
you know i was getting a lot of low like
stuff but
i'm honestly just confused by like 90
percent of what's showing up on my feed
like i said i [ __ ] hate tick tock go
up to the top
uh this track of course is you gay by
kira
or kyra by the way the oriental is the
best
okay well all right so here's ian
and right off the bat i gotta tell you
this one is uh we got arabic pretty
strange oh my god that is not arabic my
friend
oh wait that is in the top yeah i was
seeing the russian letters over here
you think i don't know the difference
between arabic and russian writing
you think i'm dumb don't you i well i it
was my mistake i was looking at the
russian i didn't notice the arabic to
the side are you seeing what's on here
oh [ __ ] are we on spook talk
this is cursed ian wins yeah this is
this is a [ __ ]
wait go up what's the name of the
account deeptree 666. yeah this is
pretty good ian to be honest i was
getting a good amount of this kind of
[ __ ] too but none of it showed up when
we scrolled so
let's talk
that's crazy don't care you're drunk
shut the [ __ ] up i kind of love that
meme who the [ __ ] ass lol not me so stop
talking this rules
i want to send this to somebody oh we
should drop this under trisha's tweets
[Music]
[Music]
all right here's number three here we go
yo what the hell yours is so good
we got shrek doing the uh just bombs
flying damn this got the whole thing
let's get out of control it's very much
early youtube vibes yeah
[Music]
this is very similar to mine
okay ian wins
so what would you call this a deep fried
crap post crap post it
like yesterday 21st century humor oh
this is this is future humor
we're in the 21st century this is modern
day humor there you go well we're in the
return of the 21st century yeah we're 20
years in now
yeah first part
this is like
all right video proof that skinwalkers
exist oh we're going to have another uh
creepy one i have a feeling
basically scary
[Music]
oh that was the truth all right that was
the proof
okay are you a ghost talk is that what
i'm in a little spooky talk they're
witches skinwalkers
are people i've noticed tick tock has
this thing about skin walkers which i've
never heard of but they seem to love
skin water you know it's very popular
with the younger generation like olivia
knows what i'm talking about because she
was freaked out whenever we said
skinwalkers you know about that
yeah jenna and julian used to talk about
like spooky stories on their podcast and
they would talk about skinwalkers it's
like a bigfoot are they serious about it
no i mean
it's like speculation about it but do
people believe this doesn't look very
serious this video
ethan did you not see the proof no i see
the proof there's just should i pause it
yeah pause it let's take a look here
there's there it is okay i mean that's
pretty slam dunk right there
i know like a lot of like kids will get
together and like watch videos of
hearing skin walkers scream and it like
freaks them out and they think it's the
coolest [ __ ] ever yeah i think it's a
creepy costume okay great next all right
fifth here we go
so we have
oh friday okay
ready i mean that's kind of ignoring me
to be honest yeah that's not true
anything to do with five nights at
freddy's is pretty normal i'm from hell
whoa
hell yeah somehow it has been tagged
lgbt
and james charles
and james charles please oh inside my
mouth literally tag james charles police
nut inside my mouth
is a hashtag wow
what the [ __ ]
is the first first
thing i was extremely cursed wow didn't
expect that one all right here we go uh
beans more
okay this this is one of those modern
day 21st century humor
it's very avant-garde
i don't know about this one
could be better that one's more like
20th century uh humor if you ask me you
get scared easy click off of this one
[Applause]
wow
oh my god guys
this one i'm not feeling i get scared
relatively easily and i gotta say this
is the same that's scary you're scared
it's just not that scary
[Music]
all right here's eight
type
uh this is
i don't like this is a corpse husband
music video
yeah it looks like it
don't hey no corpse hey no
no corb slander here
that shit's worse than k-pop fans i know
what can i do to make it up to the
corpse
don't come for me i didn't say anything
negative oh i know what you meant i just
thought it looked like for dan not me
is is this corpse breathing
i don't think so yeah that's worse
there's corpse i know that breath
anywhere the signal for corpse it's not
this it's like
gripping something really hard and
showing your like veins pop oh that's
true yeah that's the corpse
just point you know this your friends at
3 am and say nothing well
oh this is connie's sample yes
he's doing miracles on ian i don't know
about it you know i feel like my page is
not
as spicy as it was well there was i felt
that way about my mind
and there was some really good ones in
it
you know some misses but overall it was
pretty i think we technically have one
more here's we got one more chance here
we go
navy federal he's loving that atm bike
you know
a little disappointed yeah it started
really strong it started very long it
was like oh my god oh that's the most
cursed thing is just like that yeah
i had it i was swiping last night and
sam
like actually was disturbed by some of
the weird [ __ ] that i was getting on my
page and this is just not it's not that
well that first one was great i think i
don't think you should be you shouldn't
be too disappointed i was impressed
overall with the and it was unique it
was a different thing you know there was
no um
there was no
let's just say i liked it there was no
breastfeeding thank you for example
i liked it a lot of you yeah yeah i
liked it so i just
appreciate it i just logged out of ian's
and so this is this is a not logged in
account and the first video and all of
you you all use tick tock so maybe
you'll be like yeah then we've all seen
it but
this appears to be a recreation
yeah this guy kadly lame is the
this is the guy this guy's like becoming
the number one biggest tick tucker so do
you just steal the the video
no no no no that's a viral vid that uh i
think is fake
but uh
someone else the
what do you mean he did his soul the
original video is a viral clip yeah you
used to show it on the podcast all the
time you had a button but it was a
different but it was a different video
yeah
somebody did
their own i think it's fake he's
stealing it well no he that's what he
does he does a stitch of a video and he
just gives like a normal reaction and he
has like over 100 million followers i'm
not talking listen i'm not talking about
this guy in the video i'm talking about
this guy yeah yeah he is trying to
recreate it on the show it's fake
okay
he's no we haven't talked about this
version of it on that i think i we've
had a discussion about it was in
whatsapp i think i sent it and i was
like that's fake yeah yeah i called it
let's watch it one more time though
[Music]
i gotta say i don't get why this guy's
so popular but i'm just a hater old [ __ ]
so i don't know well because people all
like overreact on tick tock he just like
will give a normal reaction or a normal
solution as to whatever the situation is
at hand
okay boomer
all right anyways we have love as the
final uh account to inspect so give me
one moment i'm gonna set up loves so
love has been talking a big game yeah he
is and you've you've been putting a lot
of time into this one love
well oh yeah well i was really
disappointed until i woke up this
morning and it was like literally chef's
keys
oh so you're saying
it marinated and came out perfectly this
morning don't come don't get too
confident because that's literally what
happened to me and then mine was back to
being pretty weak when when i pulled it
yeah so that's that's what happened
all right let's roll the dice here we go
here is love's account i see that you
have the stretched out kanye as your
profile picture
oh yeah i customized it a bit something
i immediately noticed so sorry for the
schedule been losing motivation
already
yeah this seems like a bit normal to be
honest a little bit
zoom out
oh no i thought never mind okay okay so
are we gonna be rolling
[Music]
poster is up wait oh my god
oh
so
this is very similar to ian's this is
21st century very similar they just used
the same sound and put in a bunch of
weird memes i guess so
this is some advancement it's less
surprising after i've seen it so many
times right yeah
well you'll see it a bit more okay let's
see all right here we go what what the
[ __ ] you doing
beat his ass
[Music]
never mind i i saw that going somewhere
else
okay boomer
that this video yeah where could this
video go maybe where did you see it
curious where you thought
might have some racist lyrics you saw i
saw two towers oh okay
okay yeah see uh already it's flopping
puppies dancing love
love this is wholesome come on dude
you can't you know what you never know
with this app that's the thing yeah it's
like
oh now you're on the desktop training
all right come on move it along let's
see what else all right let's keep going
[Applause]
[Music]
this is very good
it's a lego pop shoot assassinating uh
another lego well he's dodging all the
bullets i mean no i see blood it's
roblox i see blood bro he ain't dodging
[ __ ]
actually it's probably not that funny
though considering the soundbite is
probably
oh you think it's like real yeah stop
the sound please all right while we're
moving on yeah that's definitely a real
police shooting sound
this is really good this one's awesome
and you know what makes it even better
is that it has 333 000
like for no reason and i love that
and the music everything's on point this
is great this one's really coming again
can we get comments comment requests on
this one okay let's take a look
relatable
oh yeah relatable context still please
no information no information too
political bro
[Laughter]
um keep going
uh w always the low quality videos yeah
i mean this is a hit yeah
no this is a winner yeah we got a winner
here love
all right moving on
your
all right remember when those kinds of
memes were yeah popular it's called like
uh
god it's like a deep fry but it's some
kind of like
where you going
i'm recounting how many we saw
yeah that's a good one
so i think this is the last one this is
10.
can eat my meat
snitch
attention snitch never stop exploring
eat fresh
okay interesting uh what is this
is not a hobby
all right i uploaded a video too
so it seems like in the end it would be
between uh me and zach right you and
zach i mean ian i would say it was close
he started he started really strong but
then it kind of felt it was great i
thought he honestly i thought his was
great through no it's through like five
nights at freddy's
yeah
actually of those yeah there was
probably there was maybe two or three
five night at freddy's on your feet yeah
right but i did like the copy pasta
spooky spooky fest so i guess do we uh
take a vote on who's the champ all right
zachary then yeah it's gotta be zac or
ethan right so uh hands up for zach
hands up for zach
wow two hands a b
judas
never missing i didn't see anyone else
with their hands up so i was i was like
i gotta support my voice yeah just
kidding and then for ethan
i know i think
they love me
they really love me yeah no it was good
it was good i'm surprised i didn't you
know but thank you i mean i tip my hat
to you i think all it means and and well
done to zach and honorable mention to
ian i think all it means is that i spend
more time on the toilet than you guys
that's about perfect my feed that is
absolutely a fact
it was fun though tick-tock is weird as
hell boy yeah i'm still i'm just not a
fan
on the whole and i know i know i'm a
hater yada yada good morning my friends
of tick-tock above 18. i feel bad we
didn't get olivia involved i feel like
you could have had a pretty [ __ ] yeah
that was a mistake next time we've next
time to ask you yep what was that one
thing you were telling me which talk
oh yeah i'm on witch talk oh witch talk
big time oh they're like real witches
and [ __ ] yeah and they some of them
sound like
like you know when people have exorcisms
and they have that like crazy voice it's
like that and they're putting hexes on
can you do it can you absolutely not
yeah that's a little example yeah
i like that yeah wait one more time
just like that just say this is witch
stock this is quick you know
if you want to create a cursed one you
can come in for an honorable mention on
friday oh that's not a bad idea or next
week i'll work on it yeah yeah
put together a little fresh account
i don't know i'm kind of salty over this
i'm salty i mean yeah i kind of get it
because again mine might be your
a lot stronger i went on my phone right
now and it's back to normal like it's
been like
like it was here put your phone up to
the screen and give us ten give us a two
three scrolls and let's see okay put
your phone up to the screen let's see
yellow test you're saying he's stealing
it
okay we've got uh they're like
luigi
luigi
uh there's too much glare yeah
this shot is see some cuticles
this right here is like our stick doc
your screen's a little cracked love i
don't know if you know about that
i'm with love i don't know where all
those women came from seriously are you
trying to show me uh yeah
maybe yours was probably see that's why
i'm not buying it because he showed me
on his phone earlier and it was and it
was all the women
that's what i'm saying it's the same
[ __ ] it's two thousand i was showing him
to show him like i don't know where this
all came from
yeah you know where
i think it's coming from
where the [ __ ] that came from like i
just opened mine and there's some cursed
[ __ ] on yeah the mobile's all different
dude no
breastfeeding videos maybe really
i was never breastfed so
only formula i mean i'm googling around
right now to see if like people are
talking about it being different on pc
versus on uh
phone and i'm not seeing anything of
anybody complaining about that so i
think you guys are just salty i'm sorry
my phone's definitely different too i'm
looking oh my god salt salt salt salt
shame i mean ethan's was like
he said it was gonna be a bunch of
maggot stuff it was exactly that yeah
yeah it kind of refutes the desktop
theory yeah like it's all mega thirst
traps bro i don't know
i don't know can we talk about that
paulie shore left a comment on this can
i mention this
legendary so we posted this uh the clip
of uh the shut up b word that zach sound
by that we were all we played on
yesterday's episode right
and it's on our h3 podcast tick tock
page and paulie [ __ ] sure of all
people in the world
i sent a screenshot if you want to throw
it up i sent it in uh uh what's that and
what's up okay
but paulie shore commented
yo bros
sounds like trisha got her melon a
little tweaked bro
he's like what
what the [ __ ] is polly short talking
about why are you up on the screen now
what is this why is polly's short
commenting on a highlight on our clip
knowing youtube drama
god bless paulie yo bros
he's so pure yo bro sounds like trisha
got her melon a little sweet bro hey
buddy
like 60.
i don't really be
pure isn't really what comes to mind
when i think of paulie shorts hey
holidays polly's short probably sure i
mean
yeah i mean probably 50s i would guess
he's like short age neck and neck yeah
53 yeah
but like damn he i was just thinking
like there must be some kind of history
between him and trisha you know there is
um maybe
wait is this full didn't trisha mention
uh was it working at the comedy club or
the comedy store
yeah she said she sold meat outside oh
so he probably bought some meat he
bought some bad meat off her ass
could be yeah he hasn't let it go man
about it
yeah but i don't even actually know what
it means the comment he left yo
bros sounds like trisha got her melon a
little tweaked bro
you gotta read it like paulie shore for
it to make sense i tried yo bros
sounds like trisha got her melon a
little tweaked bro
yo bros sounds like trisha got her melon
a little tweaked bro hey buddy buddy
she's throwing a buddy at that buddy is
he saying her brain is he talking about
her brain is that that's what i think
yeah melon like you're like
this clip doesn't even have her talking
i'm so confused why is paulie short in
our comments maybe he's a fan maybe he's
a fan of the fantasy podcast let's see
if he follows
let's do a test probably sure where the
i'll send you a screenshot
on this chord he doesn't follow me
hmm he only follows four accounts
one of them is trisha no i'm just
kidding it's just four random ass people
uh here's a tweet from trisha in 2013
couldn't last one full week following
paulie shore on twitter his twitter like
his career is dead
don't find your childhood idols on
twitter definitely the circles
wow that was eight years ago though yo
there's definitely beef there is
definitely beef there's bad meat was
sold
and that ain't just a euphemism oh no
know your way around some meat bad no
olivia gave me
[Music]
i'm making meats now smoking these meats
here
i'm the meat chef
all right we should go how long we've
been going because there's a lot of good
stuff left right uh yeah it is also 6 30
p.m
right how long we've been going uh like
an hour 40.
so do you want let me just do one more
quick thing okay
uh logan paul stealing adobe stock
photos to make them into nft oh god yeah
because you know how logan paul had the
the [ __ ] was it called
ding-dong
he tried the ding-dong thing and now
he's launching a new nft
um project called crypto zoos
and he said he spent a million dollars
on this huge project
about uh these this huge project of
digital art one of a kind
so dude nfts are so [ __ ] out of
control bro this is literally what he's
selling this is the stock photo and this
is the
million dollar nft
i wrestle the bear
how long would this take you to make ian
uh
i mean cam could whip this up real quick
yeah cam can make this in 10 seconds
yeah i mean cam how long would that take
you to make
while i'm talking about this does he
have his headphones on
he says show it again yeah so while
we're talking about this make a z crypto
zoo nft
and maybe
okay so he said name two animals what
you got a uh ryan cavanaugh
and a pig
humans are animals too yeah guys that's
true
here's more of uh
look this is [ __ ] the million dollar
nft project here's the stock photo that
you can get from adobe stock and this is
the [ __ ] nft they really think you're
dumb that one's kind of cute i'm not
gonna lie
no i agree well how much are they
selling this for
he says he spent a million dollars
preparing on the project
i'm a mother freaking blooper regardless
of
whether he's lying or he got ripped off
by an artist uh for a million dollars uh
i'm wondering what they're selling them
for
i don't know if they've launched it yet
but i'm pretty sure they're gonna be
trying to make a lot of money
he's calling it cryptozoo yeah
well let's uh uh here is a lion stock
photo from adobe stock with a kitten's
face
that one i don't like
but again it's like whatever it's like
you can do this in first year
yeah i know it's uh
well uh
cryptozoo.co is this uh
is this the project
it's definitely some sort of yeah
collect and breed exotic animal hybrids
that yield
dollar signs zoo on the blockchain oh
here's their i mean this has got to be
it
super rare lion plus kittens
clinton
super rare yield 18 000 zoo per day bro
what are you even talking about
oh then everyone's posting the
adobe stock art that they
they just respond with you they even
have the license like i don't even know
that you can legally steal that or use
that use the art in that way i just got
to be careful to not like disrespect the
culture oh my god you can easily buy
stuff off of you know adobe stock is
like uh getty images or something you
you can so i mean maybe that's where the
million dollars that he spent went is
licensing all of these images
so yeah i'd love to know how much
they're selling this stuff for but
actually i don't really care at the end
of the day either i'm trying to
investigate on his uh i found their
instagram page for the project to see if
there's like prices listed but one thing
coffeezilla did to use that i'm excited
about
the last night he tweeted this and i'm
super excited
i found logan paul's crypto wallets
something that he thought he found his
wallets and that like he had never
scammed or done anything because you
know these guys have multiple wallets
like one for public facing and one where
they do all the shady dump like rug
pulls so he's saying he found logan's
paul's wallet so stay tuned i'm excited
very interesting
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for letting me know all right well we'll
see we'll see
we'll see if you give a [ __ ]
yeah that's about it i thought it was
interesting
so yeah the the linton can be yours for
a hundred thousand dollars
for a hundred thousand dollars i just
made that up oh okay i was like oh my
god
anyway coffee said it gives him this
vibe it's a spongebob meme of course
pretty much all right cam what you got
oh so cameron is done he we've made our
own cryptozoo nft are you ready
to
that's not a pig
oh god we failed i guess it's harder
than we could
you said
because he's not on mike he said i
thought you said kid yeah he just made
right i guess it's harder than we
thought
sort
we missed the mark on that one we really
missed the mark on that i was like what
the hell am i looking at that [ __ ] is so
good though
uh yeah
oh
you could take another crack at it real
fast
all right
oh my god
so let me see while cameron works on
that you have one minute to make a
hundred thousand dollar crypto zoo and
if 60 seconds came let's go
put on the clock i'm i i just started
the clock you and use this stock photo
of a pig
excuse me
for the sake of brevity you'll probably
just pull from google images or
something but right
so anyway
oh he's done already he's done that was
already done
all right cryptozoo
if i'm gonna make any changes
oh my god one of a kind here it is
we have invested over a million dollars
to bring you this one-of-a-kind
cryptozoo
cam looks like one of those hackers
right now in the movies they do the
cliche like gabby
can we get a shot of cam working on his
million dollars not easily really well
maybe he's trying
here's cam working
uh i can't see him here's cam working
tirelessly come on you're right where
the clock is kicking cam don't worry
oh it's already oh you got it okay here
we go
hey
[Applause]
fantastic and we'll be putting that on
the blockchain that's right we've spent
years and and countless tens of
thousands of dollars on this project
jesus looks just like him actually yeah
you think he's ever [ __ ] a pig
i would guess
no but i um
don't
technically have any way of knowing that
for sure so it's not really my place to
say whether or not
he has [ __ ] the pig i'm not saying
ryan kavanagh's [ __ ] the pig
how could i know that yeah there's no
i'd rather speak up and be wrong
and be wrong if you show the picture
is that if he did [ __ ] a pig and they
somehow bred
which isn't possible because that their
dna isn't actually compatible between a
pig and a i'm a [ __ ] savage
but it but if somehow it was well
it would look like harvey weinstein
just like that
all right guys that's about it eh yep
are you talking about [ __ ] a pig over
there greg
you gotta do it literally yeah that is
very savage all right listen
anything else greg
he's a gp's yeah he's out no hero okay
good me too
all right guys we'll see on friday for
after dark
adios
[Music]
me